[Music]
so just moments ago the Washington Post
put out a report look at the title the
sleeper cells have awoken Trump and AIDS
shaken by resistance op-ed the sleeper
cells in our government all right
joining us for the reaction to this
breaking news author of the bestseller
why we fight recovering America's will
to win Fox News national security
strategist dr. Sebastian corker also
author brand-new book just out to day
you can get your copy mad politics
keeping your sanity in a world gone
crazy which it is dr. Gina Loudon is
with us also a Donald Trump for
president 2020 media advisory board
member of full disclosure you know I'm
thinking about this we aired in my
opening monologue crisis to crisis
Crisis crisis crisis we had to this week
Woodward and now we got this crazy
anonymous gutless cowardly New York
whoever the person is that they yes here
is a madness to this and and your
background and your book discusses this
arrangement what do we call it well yeah
Trump derangement syndrome I mean Sean
that's what most people have called it
to this point but my book actually uses
science in real data and true
psychological theory to explain why is
quite possible that this president is
the most sound minded person to ever
occupy the White House you were just you
literally liberals hands are gonna
explode at what you the madness is just
watching them go crazy over the fact
that he's really pretty unfazed by them
and I believe that and I know and that's
what drives him nuts and that's what
drives them Mike McCurry wrote an idea
all the best thing you do for Trump is
just ignore here's what I want to know I
say they're like drug addicts in the
media they wake up every day and they're
like addicts and if they don't get their
fix their fixation their hate for the
day they break out into sweats and they
go into convulsions eventually they've
got to have their drug hating Trump is a
drug to them yeah and we have to watch
it you know spewed across our television
or written into clickbait headlines
every single day and that's why you know
books like mine that just tell the truth
and take an honest approach using
science you
you know you look at Woodward's book for
example Sean Woodward doesn't know the
president
I don't know he'll graduate courses he's
taken in psychology we do know you do
know the president yeah I do and I know
his family and I know the people around
him I've seen him
relaxing what I like to call his natural
habitat of mar-a-lago I've seen him in
the White House and and you know him and
you know how focused he is how much he's
enjoying his job how genius and how
unaffected he is by that that's the
thing that really stands out and dr.
Gorka you worked in the White House and
jeana's right he's not affected by this
he engages any fights and maybe so
people don't like his style okay I can
live with that but when he's fighting
for America and we're paying 70 cents of
every dollar for NATO and he lowers that
burden and when he tells our allies
they're not going to abuse us with
horrible trade deals and he's
negotiating with little Rocketman and
he's winning and no more rockets are
going over Japan that's a good fight
that the American people or
manufacturing jobs coming back we're
winning what the left-wing snowflakes
will never understand Sean is that he
loves this he loves the fight he is a
brawler and he always wins two examples
four months he's been talking about fake
news and the conspiracy to constantly
attack him and the media the mainstream
media denies it denies it denies it and
what happens 10 days ago
300 newspapers have a coordinated
conspiracy to attack him and they do it
overtly for a year and a half we've been
talking about the deep state the deep
state the deep state and CNN and
everybody else says it's bogus it
doesn't exist what happens today Sean we
have the op-ed in The New York Times we
have the article in The Washington Post
where they say yes we are the deep state
we are proud of it and I'd like all your
viewers to look up the word sedition in
them in their dictionary go to the
Merriam Webster's and look it up
sedition it is the overt or covert
subversion of a constitutional lawful
authority and that's what these people
are doing but they must be read it out
they must be fired
they really do want to destroy him
there's no doubt this is what they want
to do well they're desperate because
he's taken away their very cushy
lifestyles their power and their money
or at least he's threatening to buy you
know cleaning house which is exactly
what the American people elected him
Shawn and I think the American people
are realizing that more and more that's
why his his popularity has increased so
much with minority voters for example
because they're seeing the results of a
president who is focused who is
interested in making never talk about
that dr. Gorrie they never told a good
story no of course they can't because
they still think that Hillary's should
be the president they didn't win the
election look at what they're doing the
Cavanaugh hearings they will use every
underhanded way to subvert this
president but they will never win
because he's never going to give up on
America sure no way
Congrats on the success your book I know
congratulations we're proud and deluxe
and the book is out today
amazon.com all over bookstores